on your story win you're only the third
woman
in the academy's history to win the best
uh director uh trophy so can you talk
about this historic win for you and
congratulations
well i'm very proud to have won tonight
um for my film and for my crew and for
my cast but also just to be another
another woman
who's going to be followed by fourth or
fifth or sixth seventh and an eighth i'm
very excited by um the fact that this is
moving fast now
you know we need it equality matters
you your film had 12 oscar nominations
tonight it's obviously very loved can
you just talk a little bit and just take
a moment to to just praise all the
amazing folks that worked on this film i
would really love to do that it's um
it's impossible to win an award like
best directing
without having an extraordinary team
behind you and you know i'm particularly
thinking of my lead actors who
really gave everything and dug deep to
portray these characters
benedict cumberbatch kirsten dunst
cody smith with fee and jesse plemmons
and then
there's actually a
raft of amazing other craft people like
arie wagner
amazing young woman cinematographer um
who i i think is just such a great
photo storyteller and always stretching
for the poetic and grant major my
designer just incredible
johnny greenwood uh beautiful music
extraordinary guy um sound team and
peter scroborous for the editing and
there's even people that aren't
nominated here today that i really like
to yell out to like noriko watanabe
who's been working with me for 27 years
and did makeup
and kirstie cameron with her costumes
thank you
a lot of people have been saying that
you are due for this oscar so does all
feel right in this moment to you
i don't know if it feels right when i
look at the other oscar nominees for
best directing i think they're all
extraordinary directors and i've you
know learnt at their feet so um
you know maybe this time it's me but you
know maybe it's a lottery i don't know
but i'm proud
and grateful to the academy for uh
choosing me on this occasion
hi jane congratulations
thank you very much yeah it's a
tremendous film and i just wanted to say
congratulations also for winning for
directing after winning for riding the
piano almost 30 years ago i'm wondering
how this experience feels different to
you than that experience
especially because you've been so vocal
about bringing a lot along a lot of your
collaborators throughout your career
through this process including a lot of
your female collaborators and you get to
celebrate that tonight as well
just going back 27 years ago when the um
when i won best uh original screenplay
i had my daughter four months in my
belly
and so it was a very different
experience you know and this 27 years is
a long time and you know i've been
chugging away doing things and so it's
this is like a real comeback and it's
beautiful to feel that you can do that
you can keep developing as a director
and get stronger and um
you know i love working with women
because they're
because of the beautiful qualities of
you know they're maternal they're
outspoken they're emotional
they're truthful they're real and
they're incredibly freaking talented
i just wanted to know because it's such
a uh
dark film at times what was the most
challenging part for you as a director
well darkness never bothers me you know
what i don't like about darkness is when
people cover it up
what i think is you know great was when
you're making films that you're
exploring it and you're looking at
complexity and you're dealing with it
and you're
and and and also our film you know was
written by a guy called thomas savage
who who wrote about cruelty
but but he was looking for kindness
really thinking about kindness so
these are the things that um
uh you know a challenge to me i mean
there's so many challenges actually i
mean i could really go on about it every
day is a challenge
but um
[Music]
it's it's just an awesome awesome thing
when you have a story that is so layered
that is so deep that it really really
challenges you in every corner of your
psyche to to reach inside yourself and
honor it
congratulations from sydney town thank
you
it is so good to see you holding that
oscar for best director in your hands
jane
what will it take for all the nominees
in that category to be women and when do
you think we'll see that
well i mean um
i don't know what it's going to take but
we're doing
you know like we we're going one by one
and um that's uh that's a nice dream i
like it you know
thank you it's that's a good dream i'm
really enjoying it but you know i i i'm
someone that doesn't really think about
um too much
you know
my fellow artists genders you know i
really love i really love great work
when people do it and i don't care who
they are or where they come from i'm
just like moved by it
and you know what is i guess very
gratifying is that um
very often these days it's women because
they've got this energy they've been
emboldened i think by the metoo hashtag
movement
to um to feel this is their time
and you know i think we're going to see
a lot more of exciting film coming from
women so that makes me excited thank you
you